the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode hey
good morning everybody it's Mike it's uh
Thursday April 27th uh tomorrow's the
last trading day of the month uh this
year is starting to go by pretty quick
and you know today I got a I got a great
presentation for you it's about how to
master order flow analysis when you
think like an Institutional Trader right
and today
what you're going to learn what I hope
to impress upon you at the end is
you know exploring the different order
flow techniques and selecting the best
suited technique for your trading style
you know order flow is information
that's generated from the market and
it's very robust there's a lot of
information that you can get you know in
the past or when you're new to trading
right if you come you start looking at a
Candlestick chart right or a bar chart
and really all you you're really looking
at is the price
you know where the market opened up for
a period what the high was what the low
was what the close and with order flow
it takes it a step further by looking at
the volume and how it traded you know on
the bid and on the offer and you know
you can use that information to make
better trading decisions I'm going to
show you how to Leverage The Power of
order flow analysis to easy easily
identify key trading areas right I mean
that's the whole point of
finding an edge is you know finding
these key areas where a market can uh
turn from right can reverse and start a
move in the other direction or you know
if a move is going signs in the order
flow that is going to continue going in
that direction
and how to identify order flow setups
using the analysis that I'm going to
teach you to minimize trading risks
right everyone always says
you know it could be you want to be a
successful Trader you got to manage your
risk and you know a lot of Traders think
that oh you know I'm using a stop so I'm
managing my risk well you know a lot of
times Traders use basically an arbitrary
stop based on you know an arbitrary
dollar value but really the way you know
professional Traders do it is they use
information that's generated from the
market to hide behind in a way right
that you know where support is is or
where resistance is or where a market
you know is showing signs of exhaustion
right where no more Traders aren't
interested to trade anymore so for those
of you that are new to one of my
presentations you know just a brief uh
background on myself I've got over 20
years of institutional trading
experience right I spent eight years at
JP Morgan Futures on the trading desk
right literally coming in at 5 45 in the
morning until
you know almost five o'clock in the
evening uh prior to that I was with
Cargill the big commodity trading firm
in the U.S
I was also with Commerce Bank for almost
four years as a licensed your ex Trader
right where we traded
um you know the Buns bobbles shots
against the you know the US 10 years
the five years the two years even the 30
years as well as you know Dax and Euro
stocks prior to those with EDF man the
big English commodity Trading Company
for a couple years and I started on the
cme4 with Dean Witter right back in the
the early 90s and you know the reason I
talk about this is because you know I'm
one of only a handful of former
institutional traders who have mastered
both trading order flow and teaching it
to retail Traders around the world right
so thinking as an Institutional Trader
can seem like a difficult process but
with a little focus and dedication
everyday retail Traders can begin to
think like an Institutional Trader
simply by studying order flow
you can learn to identify buying and
selling patterns that big institutional
Traders often leave behind in the market
so let's take a look at the exact steps
you need to follow to start immediately
taking advantage of that institutional
order flow that's taking place in the
market every day you know if I had to
break down sort of the percentage of
institutional order flow in the market
it's you know they all say Al goes you
know hfts Algos you know make up 80 of
the market but that's not really what
drives the market right those hfts the
Algos they provide that liquidity it's
the institutional Traders the big
Traders you know the the other time
frame Traders if you will that are
taking a big macro View and they have
the Deep Pockets to move the market
continue it in a Direction
but before we jump in you know just a
brief disclaimer I do want you to
understand that you know trading
involves risk and
an investor you know a Trader can
potentially lose all or more than an
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
your financial security
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and those with sufficient risk
Capital should consider trading right I
mean you gotta understand that you know
sometimes people think that oh you know
I lost my job I've got Severance that's
going to last for three months unless
start trading well you know you're
putting yourself in a disadvantage if
you do that right the markets are there
they will be there tomorrow and the next
day you know take your time to learn to
trade properly so let's jump in
so when you look at a chart really what
are you looking at right we all start
at some point you know we open up our
computer we see a chart and say oh yeah
would have been great if I could have
bought down here and sold up here but
when you're looking at a chart really
all you're doing is just seeing what
price did right where price traded at
it's not really telling you anything
else it's not telling you about the
conviction of buyers and sellers what
they're actually doing in the market so
once you actually start
considering what's actually happening in
the market then you can understand how
bars form right in the old days right we
don't have trading pits anymore
where people are you know yelling and
screaming they're basically they're
bidding and they're offering right
they're trying to transact
uh trades you know they're trying to
transfer risks from themselves to
another Trader or maybe take on risk
so basically what you see on a chart is
is trading taking place there's buying
and selling
and if you're looking at your normal
Candlestick chart you don't see the
intensity of that trading you can't see
that you know maybe there was
on the move down that you know even
though they're selling right we're going
down that the selling is getting weaker
than at the low you know aggressive
buyers are stepping in strongly right
you don't see that on a
normal bar chart right because a normal
bar chart basically treats all trades
equal right all prices equal meaning
whether you know if the market traded
40.96 when you're looking at your bar
chart it doesn't tell you how much
transacted there and that's important
right if if you've ever run a business
you know that you know it's a simple any
business right a simple lemonade stand
simply selling something right you know
that as if you you know you get a lot of
buyers oh my gosh I got to raise prices
because you know I'm going to run out of
everything you start then the buying
decreases same thing if you keep
lowering your prices you're going to
track more and more buyers coming in but
then eventually you're going to run out
of supply and that's you know that's how
the markets operate but on a normal bar
chart you're not really seeing that
information that volume that's going
through because you know at the end of
the day if you've ever like I said if
you ever run a business
you just don't look at everything
that you sold right you say oh this is
great you know at 40.96 I sold
tractors well you want to know how many
tractors you sold right or how many
bicycles you sold at a price so you
could accurately price your inventory
and the market is the same way now
you know maybe about 15 20 years ago you
know some Traders got together they
formed
um you know they figured out a way to
take that information from The Exchange
because the information is there it's
available for everybody you don't have
to pay extra to see the volume right
that's that's there especially now we're
in a computer age that you know
everything is traded electronically so
every transaction that goes through is
information
and what they did is they these Traders
they they developed what's called a
footprint chart right which shows you
the volume that's traded on the bid and
the volume traded on the offer
and from that
you can extrapolate you know whether
there's
um you know aggressive buying or
passive selling or just normal
transactions going back and forth right
just people Trading normally
okay and because again not every price
trades the same you know some prices
have very little trades
other prices have very heavy trades
right and by trades I mean volume right
volume is important to traders to
understand because
if
you have areas of thin volume meaning
you know the market didn't spend much
time there because the market is moving
fast and it didn't really have much
um buying and selling taking place you
know that means something to a Trader
now in about I think 2013 2014 and then
finally in 2015 I released a software
called the order flows Trader software
which is a footprint chart like on
steroids basically and what it does is
it helps Traders understand
see a lot better where
there's Market generated information as
support or resistance coming into the
market right here's resistance coming in
here here's support right you can see
how the market
was going up and it came right down to
this support level from before and as
the market is trading it's forming in
real time
a resistance area
okay now you know I'm throwing around
these terms you know but I just want to
spend a little time explaining them
first aggressive Traders passive Traders
you know it's not just trading there's
two types of Traders there's aggressive
Traders and there's passive Traders
what a aggressive Trader is is someone
who pays the market price when they're
buying or sells at the market price as
opposed to a passive Trader which is
someone that's working a bid or working
an offer so think about it for a second
a market is say five bit at six
you have people trying to buy fives
people trying to sell sixes that is the
liquidity in the market right now
someone is bidding five someone else is
offering it at six they are the passive
Traders now if they just sit there and
don't move you know their price up or
down
Market's not going to trade it's just
going to be five six all day what it
that what you need for a trade to happen
is an aggressive Trader to come in
either somebody that was sitting on the
bid at five or somebody coming into the
market saying oh you know what hey I
think this Market's going up I'm gonna
buy the sixes right that would be the
aggressive Trader or say somebody coming
in that's working an offer at six they
can oh you know what
you know I just got a call from somebody
you know they've got they're looking to
sell so I'm going to jump in front I
might be aggressive I'm going to sell
the fives right that would be the
aggressive trade or someone that crosses
over that bid offer line
now it's from
the passive buyers
and aggressive traders that you get more
information okay you're gonna get
a piece of information called Delta okay
Delta you can see on this chart here is
on the bottom and basically it's the net
difference out of in a bar between the
aggressive buyers
and the aggressive sellers okay and why
is that important well generally as a
market is going down you're going to
have aggressive selling
right if markets going up you're going
to have aggressive binds you're gonna
have positive Delta on moves up negative
Deltas on the move down
now there are going to be some instances
where a market
is moving down and you have
positive Delta or Market is moving up
and you have you know bars that are
giving you
negative Delta right which is sort of
opposite of what you're expecting but
within you know that really what that
should do is get you asking
why is that Delta
positive on a move down well often it's
a sign of Supply coming into the market
supply that's coming in
as the market is moving down
is bearish information right and you can
see that so sometimes you can see a
market moving down
and you're going to see an aggressive
buyer okay you know
an aggressive buyers buyer or buyers
came in and we're lifting the offer
trying to take it higher but at the same
time even though you had those
aggressive buyers you had a strong
passive seller there's somebody in there
with Supply and if you know there's
Supply in the market well what's that
going to do to the market it's going to
help move it lower
just as if a market is going up right
you see positive Deltas then once in a
while you're going to see you know a
green candle as the Market's going up
with negative Delta and you're gonna say
well why is this Market going up with
negative Delta well
it would be going up with
negative Delta when there's support
coming into the market right if a market
is moving up and more and more people
are bidding as price gets higher they're
supporting that Market on the Move up
what do you think that means to the
market well it's probably going to go
higher
now the the next
piece of information that's very useful
for Traders is What's called the point
of control
point of control is the price level in
the bar that has the most traded volume
on both the bid and the offer
and it's important because you know it's
sort of the balance area if you will of
a bar you know are we trading above the
volume are we trading below the area of
the most volume and then when you start
comparing it to previous bars
it'll give you information
as to as well the direction of the
market
and oftentimes it moves
the point of control will also act as
support or resistance right on a move
down
right here we have a point of control
coming through here
and you can see it's this next bar
trades right back up to at the bar after
it trades back up to at the bar
four bars later trades back up to it and
again the next bar then we're going down
going to control the bar the next bar
trades back to that level going to
control the next bar trades right to
that level
the next bar going to control trades
within one tick of that level and you
often see that on nice moves up and
moves down when a control acting as
support or resistance
the third major piece of
order flow is imbalances right when
aggressive buyers outnumber aggressive
sellers by a certain percentage
usually four to one I use four to one
other people use three to one
and it's going to tell you that you have
strong selling if it's aggressive
selling in the bar or strong buying
strong aggressive buying people lifting
the offer okay and you know there's
certain patterns that you see in the
order flow like here you have three
selling and balances stacked on top of
each other you got another three here
right you see how as this Market is
coming down now it's telling you you
know up here that hey you get very
strong selling right you got strong
selling again down here
and the market just continues selling
off right with you can see more selling
imbalances in here just as on the move
up strong buying imbalances and you
could use these information
um
you know to confirm what you're already
thinking in the market right if if
you're long here okay say you're long
from earlier right this was uh the other
day in s PS right all got all the way up
to 30 you know 36 and a half or so you
know if you're long from you know
earlier around 25 all right and the
money you see the market trading up
you're thinking oh happy days right the
Market's moving up nicely and then it
gets slammed right here in this bar just
by looking at the the imbalances taking
place
you know you don't want to be logging
that's just your sign to get out don't
be thinking oh this Market could
probably reverse and go back up right
you're seeing wave after wave in this
bar so one minute chart two waves of
actually three you don't have a stacked
imbalance in here but you got two more
imbalances wave one wave two wave three
of aggressive selling
you know that's assigned to uh that's a
clear sign to get out of a position
rather than let it come all the way down
here and stop you out
all right you could cut your position
a little bit earlier than letting the
market come all the way down to your
stop to to
um stop you out at your full stop and
you know like I said earlier in this
presentation you know people say oh you
you got to let your winners run and cut
your losers short well how do you do
that how do you cut your loser short
that's the part that many Traders
struggle with cutting their losers short
because they don't have a way to
understand what's happening in the
market they just get long or get short
throw in their stop and take profit
and that's it right let the market come
to them either take hit the take profit
or hit the stop level well saying you
know Trading
is a little bit more
and I'll say Advanced but you know
there's another step right it's called
managing the trade and if you're reading
that there's strong aggressive selling
coming into the market why would you
leave your stop at its original level
that's your sign to get out early that's
how professional Traders institutional
Traders
are able to manage risks by recognizing
that conditions have changed in the
markets right you need a way to
understand conditions are changing in
the market right you know for us for for
myself as a small intraday Trader you
know I don't consider myself an
Institutional Trader anymore you know I
just trade for myself
but
as a retail Trader right our tool is the
order flow whereas you know the big
macro Trader you know he's he's watching
macro events right he's not
micromanaging it on a smaller chart but
you know for intraday Traders retail
traders that do trade we can watch we
could see what's happening in the market
just by watching the order flow
so again Delta point of control
imbalances are sort of the three
cornerstones of order flow
now
exploring the different order flow
techniques and selecting you know the
best suited technique for your trading
style and you know it's funny because
a lot of people don't realize that
there's many many different ways to
approach the markets and you know just
to understand that if you've ever read
you know I'm sure we've all read Market
Wizards right I know a lot of people
that got into trading because of the
book Market wizards but when you read it
you know the first edition I don't know
what there was 15 Traders or something
in there they all have different ways of
approaching the market
there's no one way
that they're all doing it they all have
their own way
okay and sometimes I see people it's
it's like they they you know we'll post
someone will post something up on
Twitter or Facebook oh yeah this is the
trade I took then people will bash them
say oh that's not how you're supposed to
trade well you know there's no one way
to trade the markets okay and
especially when it comes to order flow
it's so robust there's so many different
ways that you could use order flow and
the beauty of order flow so you don't
have to use it in isolation by itself
use it you could take it and use it with
your existing method of market analysis
so here just really briefly this I'm
going to talk about three easy order
flow analysis techniques you can use
stopping volume Market exhaustion and
when a market is out of balance so
stopping volume what do you think that
means it means
stopping a move right a brick wall is
going to stop a car and it's the same
sort of thing with stopping volume
this is five years yesterday right
Market was going up up then right here
at the High
see 1700 contracts trade on the offer
all right I know that you know this
Market I know 1700 contracts
is strong size right and it's coming in
at an extreme right it's you see the top
of these other bars right here's 561 618
187 30 300 136 226. then the market
stops up here 1700 can't go any higher
even when bid there but in trade on the
offer so I know that there's liquidity
right up in here I don't need to use a
book map or a heat map to see that
there's liquidity I just use my eyes I
could just see the volume it's heavier
than normal
all right and then a market sort of goes
sideways comes back up that level trades
89 contracts the second time so the
first time trade 1700
and it's 1700 on a bar the total volume
is 3 800. so almost half of the bar's
volume transacted right up here at the
top of the bar
then more importantly Market comes off a
little bit goes sideways comes back up
and tests it second time it only trades
89. so this time Traders are
sort of queued in on what's taking place
up here right they're saying ah there's
still liquidity up here right and
they're not interested because they know
that I don't have enough Firepower to
get past it and the market sells off
this is wheat okay
now wheat obviously different volume
constraints than say five years which I
just showed you but here's the market
it's going down down it's this area down
here 89 Lots
all right there's a
there's passive buyers down here bidding
at this low for 89 contracts right even
per second it went offered there
they bought those areas right the 42. so
I know I got heavy volume down here on
the bottom
and the market starts ticking up and
going back up right it's it's not
rocket science in the sense that oh you
got to know calculus algebra it's just
common sense okay
okay well I know that if we're running
into strong bids down in the market
right not a price floor but you know an
area where people think the market is
cheap and they're all just sitting there
waiting for the market to come for them
they absorb all that selling
and then the market starts ticking up
that's the obvious trade is to the
upside
it's not something that you guys oh you
know I got some strong buyers here I
want to get short I'm going to sell into
that no why would you do that
you should be going with the direction
of the markets
this is your sign of what institutional
Traders the big Traders are doing in the
market just as here
right you know that the big Traders are
selling it up here
okay and that's the information that
you're only going to see
by looking at the order flow if you're
looking at a normal Candlestick chart
you're not going to pick that up at all
because you're not looking at the volume
that's why I spent a lot of time harping
on the importance of volume is because
volume does matter
now Market exhaustion okay think about
it you know have you ever gone out for a
run or exercise you get tired Market's
the same way right move stop because
Traders run out of energy so to speak in
in a way they're exhausted right they've
got no more buying that they could do
they've used up all their energy which
is their energy is is buying or selling
and
when you're looking at a normal bar
chart forget about finding Market
exhaustion because it's dependent on the
volume now this is 10 years right 10
years
trade On The Board of Trade they trade
boatloads of volume this is a five
minute chart and unless you know what
you're looking at
you're not going to be able to tell
where the exhaustion is coming in
and that's why having software to
highlight that to you
is going to be useful here I see
exhaustion came in right you got this
big bar that came in on the number right
traded all the way down here big selling
get down here seven contracts this bar
traded 30 000 contracts
but only seven Lots trade on the low
that's not normal facilitation of trade
faders are done they don't want to sell
anymore they just sold 2 000 then you
know a few Traders okay let's see if we
could take it lower they sell seven only
nobody's interested the market snaps
back up and then Works its way back up
higher hits this high up here
next bar
starts coming off
you get an exhaustion print here two
contracts trade these zones are what we
call exhaustion print zones okay
and if you know this is exhaustion up
here again we just rallied all the way
up right then the next bar comes up
opens and we start trading higher okay
you know I mean every bar here opened
traded higher traded higher traded
higher then finally hit this High then
the next Bar opens up starts continuing
right here open higher open high you
know when higher traded higher okay
maybe this bar is going to do the same
it's going to start trading up and go
higher well it doesn't go any higher
and at the top of the bar you got very
thin volume you got two contracts trade
it's a bar that trades 25 000 contracts
and two contracts trade up here
what do you think the market is telling
you
it's telling you Traders are exhausted
right they don't want to buy anymore
they've bought all they can buy and once
you know that
Traders have bought all they can buy
well what's going to move the market
higher nothing
because the buyers are tired there the
market is exhausted people have been
buying it they've bought everything that
they need
and what happens you see the market
trade down
this is e-minis yesterday okay this is
you know around the nine o'clock right
going sideways going sideways and it
breaks down well on this bar
again sideways sideways sideways
basically trading between 96 and 4100
top of this bar you get that exhaustion
Prince okay so instead of just opening
up and trading back up and you know
trading in
the range that we have just been Trading
you can see you have your sign here
that there's exhaustion present
and if you have exhaustion presence
in this case this is bearish exhaustion
because it's coming in at the top of the
candle
what do you think the Market's going to
do is it going to go up no it's going to
go down next bar
sells off 10 points
all right and then drops another
you know Five Points
okay so that's how you can take
advantage of the information that's
available to you again this information
is available to everybody but you just
need
a way to format it in a way to so you
could use it in your analysis okay crude
oil
Market's going up you got your
exhaustion print you hit your high up
here
you got your exhaustion print
one contract trades one contract trades
one contract trades these are at the top
of the bars right markets going up
everyone's excited well we're gonna go
higher we're going higher
um we're not and the market sells off
okay now
there are Traders out there that
you know if you like to use support and
resistance levels if you determine if
you calculate your own or you maybe you
get some from a service
you draw them on your chart
you use the order flow right if your
level was somewhere up here
77.50 okay right sport resistance is
usually not just one price level but you
know say 77.50 to 60. and you trade back
up into that area you get you know maybe
to the other side of it and you see just
trade one lot that's your sign to short
the heck out of it because you know that
these buyers
aren't interested anymore you have that
market exhaustion right and you should
be looking for the market to sell off
that's how
order flow is used by you know traders
that have their own methods of trading
right you could take this information
wrap it around the way you're trading
right
now out of balance markets
right Humpty Dumpty sat on a wall
until he fell off and it's the same with
the markets right markets are in periods
of balance
and periods of out of balance and it's
that if you think about it it doesn't
the way balance is it's not one level
it'll balance that you know three
but then it'll go out of balance Trade
four five six seven eight nine and at 10
finds a new balance it's that area
of when it's moving from balance to
balance that moves happen that's where
Trends come in
and
when you're looking at an order flow
chart
right having
you know something having a way to
analyze
when a market is moving in balance or
out of balance is going to give you an
advantage over other people that don't
understand the mechanics of what's
taking place in the market right and you
can see as you're going up you have
buying imbalances taking place here okay
but it's one thing right if you're
looking at a footprint chart right here
you can see it if you're experienced
have software that's going to
highlight it to you okay because what
causes
a market to move from balance to out of
balance is imbalances right I know
that's
a lot of balance words but
it's hard to see sometimes when you're
looking at a footprint chart right you
see one two three buying a balances here
one two here another one two then three
up here
and then you get up to the high
up here right now again remember you
also have that exhaustion print here but
now you're starting to see selling
imbalances come in right
and again having software having a tool
that's going to highlight to you these
areas where there's
buying imbalances you know multiples
is going to give you an edge over people
that aren't even looking at volume
they're just looking at a bar chart
because you know if you're looking at a
bar chart and you see a chart like this
this is 10 rain crude crude
if you're looking at a bar chart you see
the market come up here and it's going
sideways starts breaking down bar chart
Traders will get be getting short on the
break down but if you're looking at the
order flow
okay what you have right markets going
up you've seen these green boxes around
this bar this bar this bar that's
telling you there's
multiple buying imbalances you know more
than three imbalances in a bar that are
bullish on a green candle or three or
more
selling imbalances so what happened
right we're going up you're seeing the
aggressive buying right you've seen the
buying imbalances you get up to the high
of this move
now you have this sort of Orange Box
around here which is Tommy
there's aggressive selling taking place
well where's it taking place
the high of the move
then you could add in there's that
exhaustion print that one contract
because this is the same chart as before
this is your sign okay yeah you know
what I could get short up in here around
the 77.80 stop just above you know 77
you know 95 as opposed to letting the
market you know sort of go lower come
back up go lower lower low lower high
and then finally start to break and
you're getting short at 60. you can get
in 20 ticks earlier
by looking at the order flow
right there's a market right it's out of
balance right you can just see how the
ebb and flow of the markets are taking
place markets coming down go sideways
starts going up aggressive buying coming
in okay goes up a little bit more
aggressive selling coming in one two
three solid imbalances right off the
swing high before the market drops down
quite nicely
okay so hopefully you're starting to
understand these things here's
euro currency yesterday right Market is
just sort of going sideways starting to
tick higher tick higher then it jumps
right you got this bar
three one two three four buying
imbalances in this bar right that's why
it's got this box around it
These Bars these other bars don't okay
you get long in here
uh one what is that 111 10. sorry 111
even
and it jumps all the way up to 25 two
bars three bars later
50 ticks right these trades and half
ticks
that's your sign of what's Happening
in the order flow doesn't get any
clearer okay this Market is imbalanced
now it breaks out of balance how
the aggressive buyers are coming into
the market that's your sign of a market
that's about to break out of balance
leave one balance area this area that
we're in balance before to find a new
balance area up here
all right so the second thing I'll talk
about is leveraging the power of order
flow analysis to easily identify key
trading areas you know when I when I
think about it it sort of reminds me of
um you know when you know with the
satellites sort of discovering these
ancient ruins in the middle of the
Jungle right when you're looking at a
footprint chart
and the order flow you could sometimes
see these things
that nobody else sees right because
you're looking at the market from you
know sort of a different perspective
than everybody else
okay this was yesterday in the S PS
right we remember we had this big
sell-off 4100 all the way down to 70s
okay
made it our high here and we started
coming off it went sideways then the rug
got pulled out
on the market dropped well
okay what's your sign because again you
know Market you know had the low to the
high pulled back all right buy the dip
he bought the dip he just kept dipping
all right people say well you know you
got a you know 38 retracement you'll be
looking for the market to go shoot up
well it didn't the market got pulled the
rug got pulled out and
it sold off another 25 points
and if you're looking at you know just
the plain order flow it might be hard
for you to recognize because again
there's a lot of information in here
that what was about to come right here
this move
is difficult right because you can still
see right the market is just going down
and going sideways you know what's the
clues that market can potentially fall
and
this is why having tools that help you
analyze the order flow not just present
the order flow all the trading software
has now some form of order flow
footprint chart but all they do is just
throw you a chart like this is up to you
they leave you to you
to figure out what all this means right
but when you have a simple software that
analyzes it for you tells you hey you
know what there's Market weakness here
there's Market weakness here
and so you got Market weakness that's
bearish right that's why these zones are
being drawn out well
if you know it's showing weakness in
this area here
why would you even think of getting long
you'd be thinking of being short and the
beauty of it is you just hide behind
that area of Market weakness you don't
have to have a stop up here to prove you
wrong you'll be proven wrong if you're
wrong
fairly quickly here
4103 as opposed to
you know 4110
right that's how you keep your losses
small by understanding what's happening
in the order flow when there's weakness
because if there's weakness here and the
market trades back through it well it's
invalidated the whole reason for being
in that trade is invalidated
right being able to identify this is
crude oil right Market sold off came
back up it's showing weakness here on
this move back up it's showing weakness
even though it's
markets moving up nicely
rallies from 7605 all the way up to 35
but on this move up there's weakness and
if you have weakness on a move up
well the next play is to the downside
okay now this is a bullish sign of
weakness you know I don't know how to
describe it but you know here's a market
that's more or less going sideways
dips down below sort of this range that
we had
then pops back up so you had some
selling come in here
gets below these the swing low here
but then the selling just dries up
and so if that selling dries up if
that's selling pressure is removed from
the markets
what do you think is left in the market
buying pressure
and the market has a nice rally off that
so when you're thinking of Market
weakness right it would be in terms of
selling pressure
or buying pressure the buying pressure
is getting weak
the selling pressure is getting weak
right that's why then it draws out this
area here this is where you place your
stop that's why we draw out these zones
this is mnq
you know people always ask what about NQ
or M and Q okay same concept Supply
Market has been going up it pulls back
on this pullback it gets weaker and if
you know this pullback is getting weaker
chances are it's not going to pull back
anymore it's going to go higher and it
just pops for another almost 30 points
you know Traders love to talk about how
volume is important and it is but what's
just as important as the type of volume
you know that aggressiveness of trading
or in the case I just showed you
decrease in directional aggressive
trading which is a sign that sentiment
is changing right the weakness of this
move down is taking place
okay
so this is just one of the edges you're
going to get with order flow now the
last part I want to talk about is
learning to identify order flow setups
and using that analysis
to minimize your trading risk right
think of it like this you know you're
hiding behind a wall that wall is order
flow that wall is the information
generated from the market via the order
flow
now trading is all about risk right I've
talked about this numerous times so far
let your winners run and cut your losses
small but how will you use the order
flow
okay so Market weakness as a level right
here
here okay
I know I got Market weakness here
maybe if we come back up it'll still
show weakness there because what
happened Market was going up
buyers got tired
Market sold off okay sellers are getting
tired down here
Market went back up same area sellers
aren't interested in here to where an
area where buyers lost interest I mean
eventually it's going to break out like
it did here it's not going to just go
sideways all day long
but you're starting to see how you can
use these different pieces of
information
okay
but hopefully you can start to put it
together okay here you got your weakness
all right Market was you know trading
down here came down to the swing low
starts going up sellers are are
exhausted already at this low okay so
sellers are exhausted
Market starts trading higher okay
buyers got exhausted here pulled back a
little bit went back up came back down
testing this area where you had the
weakness earlier
okay you see got within one tick and
then rallied furiously
well when you start putting it together
right what I was talking about earlier
price exhaustion together with Market
weakness
right you got your Market weakness here
Market goes all the way up comes back
down
gets back to the area where you have the
weakness earlier
and you also have price exhaustion right
Market is tired so if the market is
tired as you're going down into an area
of weakness
that's your cue
all right back up the truck get long and
where do you place your stop
just behind
the area of weakness or Price exhaustion
right you don't need to have such a wild
far-off stop based on some arbitrary
monetary level it's just right here
right you get long
here the next bar
so you're just risking basically
in this case this is a four range chart
you're raising you know five six ticks
if that you see you don't even get any
drawdown the market just immediately
just runs in that direction
all right here's e-minis okay you got
Market weakness here right Market was
sort of going sideways trying to Rally
can't go any higher Market weakness next
bar
price exhaustion next bar you even got
one two three sauna bounce right you got
that red
orange-ish box around it but really your
weakness you got your exhaustion print
this is just icing on the cake maybe you
want to add another one for that quick
move down
hold back up
back down again
Where Are You Gonna hide you're just
going to hide behind the area of
weakness or Price exhaustion
so all this information is generated
from the market and not just some
derivation of Price Right Moving
averages all that stuff is derivation
from prices just takes it to price and
looks at it over the last 15 minutes
does some calculation it comes out with
something this is based off of what's
actually trading in the market where are
you going to hide right here price
exhaustion
I say Market weakness price exhaustion
out of balance this bar right you got
the selling and balance selling and
balance selling a balance
Market just moves down nicely no heat on
the trade like this
10 years one minute chart
this time is the opposite you have
you got your swing High here came off a
little bit making a run back up towards
this high price exhaustion Market
weakness
and a nice move down you know where's
your stop it's just right here on the
other side of the market weakness and
price exhaustion
right you don't need to have some stop
further off let the market tell you
where to place your stop
bonds one minute chart
again we sort of poked down below start
coming back up Market weakness Market
exhaustion
and it's Off to the Races
okay so you know just let the market
tell you what's happening because really
you know order flow gets you as close to
the market as possible right in a sense
order flow is the market
it's nothing nothing more than the
information that's generated from the
buying and the selling
so hopefully by now you can see how
useful and the power of order flow right
because at the end of the day right it's
about finding an edge
excuse me over other Traders how are you
going to find your Edge what information
are you looking at that they're not
basically you know in the old days right
the institutional Traders we used to
have access to the trading floor we
would have them on a Squawk Box
and people would always be saying oh you
know northern's buying
um Solomon Brothers is selling
they sold 200 bonds or you know Northern
Trust bought 300 bonds that was
information that we could use as as
Traders
but now it's all electronic it's all
anonymous
but that information is available to all
of us it's all whether we want or to use
it or not right and a lot of Traders
don't
even say ah order flow that's just some
buzzword you know to get people to spend
more money on on software and stuff well
no
you know then you know if you've ever
read
you know any of these these books like
you know reminiscence of a stock
operator when was that book written a
hundred years ago a guy was a tape
reader it's a tape reading which is now
what we call order flow this is not
anything new
a lot of successful Traders have used it
for a long time right
so we've covered a lot of ground today
and
you know some of the ins and outs of
order flow and how to make smarter
trading decisions you know hopefully you
can take some of the information I've
given you and if you already have a
footprint chart you can start to look
for some of these things in there okay
and unfortunately I can't cover
everything in a quick session like this
there's just much more to learn about
order flow trading so I hope you have a
good understanding of the basics go from
the I can't attitude
to I can right are you American or
americant no
um you know it's trading is it's at the
end of the day trading is a very
daunting task okay it's it's something
that
you know it does take some effort on
your part right and for many
once they learn how to use the order
flow they see like the whole world is
opened up right they ah you know I
finally understand why the market is
moving
and when you join order flows I'm going
to share with you my most valuable
trading experiences to help guide you
and make sure that your efforts are
optimally rewarded so I've got something
special for you today okay what I've got
is
the order flows Trader software now it
runs on ninjatrader okay it'll run on
the paid version or the free version as
long as you have a real-time data feed
and it's the charts that you saw
generated in today's presentation are
from my order flows Trader
um the version most current version is
version 6.0 when we released it in 2015
you know we're now at 2023 we're on
version six so our regularly updating it
almost yearly you know a year and a half
I mean all our changes that we do get
copied by a lot of the other software
okay but the problem is they don't teach
you how to use it so if you want to get
my software get started now go to
orderflows.com oft6.html
and really what it's like it's like
you know I have this picture of the
brain plugged into the computer it's
like have you ever wished you could get
inside the minds of professional Traders
and see what they're thinking
but with order flows Trader six you can
do just that the software takes my
knowledge of trading order flow and puts
it in a program
so you can see what institutional
Traders are doing in the market and with
this information at your fingertips
you'll be able to make smarter more
profitable trading decisions okay
so if you ever felt like you've been
um struggling to understand something
right only to have it click in place
later and become easy That's The Power
of understanding how something works and
once you understand
you know how something works it just
becomes easier and take trading for
example if you don't understand how the
market works and what makes the market
move it's going to be very confusing and
frustrating
the big mistake many Traders make
is thinking that having the right
software is all they need to be
successful in trading right
have you ever bought something you
thought oh this is going to change my
life
only the thing that you bought is too
difficult to master there's not gonna be
any change okay so that's why when you
know I sell the software it's not just
software I'm selling software is just
part of it it's really the education
that comes with it because I want you to
be successful as a Trader right it's one
thing to have software you need to know
how to use it and that's why I provide a
lot of further education so you have
that solid foundation
to begin placing trades with confidence
because that's where real success
happens when you get my software you
also get access to my order flow trading
course this was the first course ever on
on trading order flow you're gonna get
access to it for free there's 20 lessons
it's over 15 hours of video instructions
and I sell this for 297 on my website
but you're going to get access to that
for free as well as a special bonus
the 56 videos series of my inner circle
that I ran a few years ago right and
honestly nowadays the only way you get
access to this is through purchasing the
software there's 56 videos on Advanced
order flow
um I don't like to say tricks but tips
and Analysis and the software well I
normally sell it for 8.99
training 297 the Inner Circle video
series 4.97 this one was sixteen hundred
dollars okay so but you're not going to
pay that today
now I realize it's one thing to learn
from videos and books but it takes
discipline and commitment
and the thing that I found to be very
useful to Traders is to have a live
training where you can ask questions now
for the last three years I've been
hosting live user training sessions
every Tuesday night
for all users of my software to come in
where I discuss order flow you know over
the past week and more importantly is
for you to ask questions about areas you
may be struggling with in your analysis
maybe you want me to take a look at a
market
right or say Mike you know what does
this mean when I see this or maybe just
need help with the software like
um you know what should I set it up for
you know what's a good setting for say
you know an e minute e-mini eight range
chart or even a 30 second chart or
whatever you know
soybeans I know you know what what type
of chart should I look at right and
again I've been doing this for over
three years now
and there's actually over 200 episodes
recorded and in the archive for you to
watch
and if you can't attend live you can
always watch the replay you know and
there are these cool gurus out there
self-proclaimed gurus who actually sell
you software like this and then charge
you extra to teach you how to use it
what the what the point is that right
you buy software you should get
education right on how to use it
effectively right I said you know I've
bought software I thought oh this is
going to be great you know I know it's
going to do that I try to use it and
it's like
you know I feel like a monkey I don't
know what the heck I'm doing is you know
what am I supposed to do now so what
I've discussed today is just a small
sample of the kinds of analysis I talk
about on a weekly basis in the live
group trainings and what can be found in
my inner circle video series so I go
into much more detail about all aspects
of trading and technical analysis the
fundamental analysis let's talk about
different trading strategies that I use
and how you can adapt them to the
changing market conditions
so if you're serious about trading I
highly suggest
and recommend you get started now you're
going to learn more about order flow in
the weekly sessions than you thought
possible
and as a special bonus for investors
Expo give you access to my order flow
Playbook
right this is a
a course that I made it's one of my
favorite courses you're going to learn
10 additional order flow trade setups
okay so what you're going to get today
is the order flows Trader 6.0 the order
flows
trading course the order flows Inner
Circle video series
live weekly Group Training the order
flow Playbook you know the values it's
almost over two thousand dollars but
you're not going to pay that because
you're going to get it all just today
for a one-time payment of 7.49
which no monthly recurring payments or
any other payments in the future
you know I hate those things where you
sign up
and then you sort of forget about it
then you build for the rest of your life
right
um you know you even cancel your card or
your bank card somehow they still manage
to take money out I I can't get that I
hate that that's why it's a one-time
payment right now obviously you will
have to pay for data fees because you
need data right you need the data from
The Exchange you have to analyze it and
you know whatever ninjatrader fees you
know if you go because my software runs
on ninjatrader
let it run on the free version Okay so
data fees you know if you're getting the
data from your broker I have CME cblt 9
Max call Max your X level one and level
two
I think through ninjatrader brokerage
I'm paying
my data fee is like 68 a month right if
you were to go to an outside data
provider kinetic or IQ feed
you're gonna pay a lot more so
um you know if you have a brokerage
account ask your broker about getting
the data feed from them so all you have
to do is go to orderflows.com
slash6.html I put the link in the chats
and it's going to take you to this page
scroll down to this bottom of the page
click on the button here it says get
lifetime access to order flow straighter
6 you can see what you get right the
order flows software order flow Trader
the Overflow trading course the order
flows Inner Circle video series access
to the weekly live group trainings and
the order flow Playbook trading course
just click here takes you to PayPal
PayPal processes
your payments all right I don't see any
of your credit card information I don't
want to see that anyway I got enough
things to deal with but it's all handled
by PayPal all right most of us are
familiar with PayPal anyway so get
started now just go to orderflows.com
oft6.html to get started now you know
for those of you that have made it all
the way to the end here I do have a
special bonus for you I didn't announce
this at the front but
I have a book on trading order flow it's
called trading order flow and I wrote
this actually before
I started the software company because
you know I sort of wanted to have a
legacy out there
you know my contribution to the trading
world so to speak so I started writing
this book
and then I that's when I thought hey you
know what why can't
order flow software do some of this
analysis that I'm writing about in this
book as opposed to a Trader having to
sit there and do all the calc you know
not calculations but do all the analysis
by themselves things like Market
weakness price exhaustion right that
information
is there just present it to everybody
let them see
what's taking place in the market but if
you want to get my book just go to
orderflows.com
book.html enter your
name and email hit submit and it'll take
you to the page you can download you can
be able to download it right you're not
going to get the actual hard cover copy
of the book just a digital download okay
so orderflows.com book.html I put the
the link for that in the chat as well
but to get started with the software
just go to orderflows.com opt6.html
so I guess I I hope you guys have
enjoyed
the
presentation today you know I see a
couple questions
um
someone was asking is is the veil for
TOS think or swim or trading view
um just struggle with you you're
struggling with the ninja and PC based
programs
um right now it's on ninjatrader okay we
are in talks to put it on a couple other
platforms part of the problem with uh
trading view is is the way they handle
the data right because you really need
the raw data from the exchange it needs
to be handled a certain way because what
they
have been doing in the past was you know
aggregating the ticks but you really
want to see it on a trade by trade basis
that goes through but you know we're
there
um you know working with a couple other
providers as well to get it on
their other platforms you know web-based
platforms so you know you wouldn't need
something like a ninjatrader or you know
something that runs specifically on on a
PC that you could access it from
um you know the web so that's in the
works but
a little bit later rather than sooner so
again you know everybody thanks for
taking the time out of your day
um you know it's summer's coming and you
know anytime you know spring and summer
comes around we always want to start
thinking about things that we can do to
improve ourselves right and you know I
really think with this package that we
put together for you you know you're
going to really improve yourself as a
Trader so thanks again everybody have a
great rest of your afternoon and again
thanks for taking the time out of your
day to come to my presentation
bye bye